c'est la tête facile sur la tête comme
ça wick les mangas exactement ce que je
voulais dire ça fait trois ans qu'elle
fait des interviews annuel elle en fait
une part en achahbar pour assumer
assurer la promo et à chaque fois c'est
les mêmes questions les mêmes
répartition cas doit faire exactement la
même chose l'année prochaine dès qu'on
leur inculque des valeurs
dès qu'elle aura quelque chose à
promouvoir donc finalement voilà moi ça
et on va passer au sujet du local au nom
le caliméro 0 est mal vu comme ça je
peux pas le laisser il continue à dire
des conneries que j'ai deux balles trois
mois comme ça et pas pour autant dire
qu'ils sont bas les couilles m'a
consulté c'est un problème tp52 parents
des gardes et du tap les gardiennes du
temple c'est les mecs comme moi à tous
les mecs à tour les johnny hallyday ks
et côtières et coûte presque journal ma
place assurée pour rentrer quant à
bernard lui croit qu'il est mis parce
qu'il aimait un bunker sa rebelle
les hells angels et asmar ton coin
soleil jeté un doute quant à l'argument
fallacieux
elles vont maintenant coquette ses
principes de tous les héritages quand tu
reçois des biens tomberont certain temps
garde certains lnm naturalisés ou est
septembre américaine normal qu'elles
vivent elles sont gentilles et ses
enfants il sur l'école là-bas voilà
chose faite évidemment astrolabe à des
idées des convictions tu change pas d'un
berger
contrairement à vous les deux bâles
prince
seulement ce moment